[Music]
a show of military strength and might as
U.S President Joe Biden welcomed South
Korean president Yun succul at the White
House
State visit is designed to reaffirm
Decades of military cooperation between
the two Nations and project deterrence
in the face of stepped up missile
testing by North Korea
that has in recent years shown little
interest in talks of denuclearization
look nuclear attack by North Korea
against the United States Earth allies
are partisans our partners is
unacceptable and will result in the end
of whatever regime we're to take such an
action the two leaders signed a new plan
known as the Washington declaration to
expand nuclear deterrence in the region
through joint exercises even though
South Korea is officially a
non-proliferation country for the first
time in 40 years U.S nuclear submarines
will be positioned in South Korea as
part of the Declaration for its part
Seoul has committed to not developing
its own nuclear weapon instead remaining
under the nuclear umbrella of the United
States and while the two leaders insist
their Alliance is strong there are
lingering tensions following the
unintended release case earlier this
month of Pentagon documents showing the
United States was spying on Soul
we need time to wait for the
investigation by the United States and
we plan to continue to communicate on
the matter
at their joint Rose Garden press
conference just one day after announcing
he was running for reelection Biden also
dodged questions about his age going
into the 2024 presidential election at
age 80 he's the oldest president in U.S
history to run for a second term I took
a hard look at it before I decided to
run and I feel good I feel I feel
excited about the prospects well
President Biden May dismiss questions
about his age and fitness as
commander-in-chief it does present a
problem for this white house hoping to
project strength and deterrence to a
nuclear foe reassuring American Allies
like South Korea Kimberly helken Al
Jazeera the White House
Samsung Electronics has reported